before we go a high school graduate in
New York made a very personal
announcement during his valedictorian
speech last week 17 year old maison
bleue called it the scariest thing and
with that maison bleue uttered the words
he got a standing ovation from his
classmates and right now he joins us in
the greenroom
so Mason tell me this how did you decide
that was a place and that was a time to
make that very personal announcement as
I was writing my speech on I was writing
about being proud of who you were proud
of what you've achieved in high school
or just any accomplishments you wanted
to be proud of
um and then I got to then and I realized
there's something that I should be proud
of that I'm hiding from everyone and it
would be hypocritical of me to tell
everyone to be proud of something and
then hide who I truly am why were you
hiding um I was I was scared of what
people would think
um I'm not the stereotypical I'm LGBTQ
kid I play sports I mask um and so
people wouldn't ever suspect me at all
but um I didn't want people to think
that they could just it would be okay to
hide because other people could feel
that way you have to submit your speech
to the school before you get the
valedictory speech right yes you didn't
include that part
oh no yeah I cut that part out because I
didn't I wasn't sure if I was gonna do
it honestly I was afraid I can force a
lot when did you know yeah um I knew for
a while tried to hide it I tried to
fight it
um no but I mean when did you know you
were bad yeah
I didn't even know if I was gonna do it
even as I got on the stage um yeah I was
told like do it if you want to don't
feel pressured and so when I got to that
and I knew it was right you've got nine
hundred thousand views so far on that
video
we heard the reaction from your
classmates are you surprised it's
completely honestly I was not expecting
this reaction at all I thought I had 14
followers on Twitter when I posted it
now I have about 2,000 and a viral video
you had told your mom who's sitting
right over there mrs. blue you had told
your mom you're gonna do it and she was
saying are you sure you want to do that
right did that give you pause knowing
that your mom was like your mom knew but
she was worried about you did that give
you pause yeah I didn't want to do
anything that would disappoint her at
all or just she wasn't worried about her
she was worried about you yeah I get
that now you didn't you weren't really
aware of the reaction at the time were
you no not at all
cuz you were you were looking down I
wasn't even looking at anybody honestly
I was trying to just say my speech and
get off the stage now that you've done
it Mason how do you feel I'm not
grateful that I did it I'm grateful for
the reaction and I'm again proud of
doing something so great I think it's
very brave I think and it just shows you
can't paint everybody with one brush
right you cannot do that all right Mason
thank you we're gonna continue our
conversation with Mason on CBS this
morning Facebook page so log on now
that'll do it for us we'll see you
tomorrow take it easy